Winning a tournament: Expectation
Winning a tournament: Reality
Excuse me...
I won the men's singles 1st place
I was wonderingif there's any prize for me?
You can have that
Is this the only prize?
Yes
Okay
Wait, wait, wait!
You still haven'tpaid your entry fee
That's 100 euros
Serving in a tournament: Expectation
Serving in a tournament: Reality
Doing a drop-shot: Expectation
Doing a drop-shot: Reality
Match point: Expectation
Come on!
Match point: Reality
Sorry man!
Bit ofan underwhelming end but...
Nah, it was good!
Around the net shot: Expectation
Around the net shot: Reality
Around the net!
Nice!
Choosing equipment: Expectation
Okay which oneshould I use today?
I think I'll go with this
Choosing equipment: Reality
I guess I'll play with this
Doing cool tricks: Expectation
Doing cool tricks: Reality
Forehand loop: Expectation
Forehand loop: Reality
First round opponent: Expectation
This will be an easy match!
Are you ready?
Yes
Very good shot!
Yeah this was a good draw!
Thanks for the match
Thankyou
It was a good warm-up match
First round opponent: Reality
This will be an easy match
Who is this guy?
Thanks...
That was a good warm-upmatch for the next round!
Playing with a new racket: Expectation
Good spin
Playing with a new racket: Reality
It's supposed to be maximum spin...
Doing the "Snake": Expectation
Doing the "Snake": Reality
SNAKE!
You read the snake spin pretty well!
Well...
There was no spin
Ghost serve: Expectation
Ghost serve: Reality
There's still 73% of you guys watching
Whohaven't subscribed
So remember to do that now
And if you haven't seen our web storeyet
Go and check out pongfinity.store
We've got some cool tabletennis products
Until next time!